quand on évoque le sujet des exercices
militaires c'est la plupart du temps
synonyme de hausse des tensions de
menaces aux frontières la russie pense
par exemple à ceux organisés en europe
de l'est par l'otan tandis qu'alain
verse l'alliance atlantique voit d'un
mauvais oeil ce organisé en russie
occidentale
mais cette fois tous ces protagonistes
se retrouvent du même côté dans des
manoeuvres organisées par la marine
pakistanaise en mer d'arabie
l'objectif favoriser la coopération
internationale pour lutter contre la
piraterie et le terrorisme
merci beaucoup dans le cadre des
exercices nous allons coopérer faire des
manoeuvres conjointes et nous ferons
preuve ensemble d'un niveau élevé de
compétences en matière navale le
ministère russe de la défense a fait
savoir que la russie était représentée
par trois navires issue de sa flotte de
la mer noire
ainsi qu'une unité d'infanterie de
marine et une équipe de démineurs même
si des bâtiments russes et américains
risquent donc de se côtoyer
il ne s'agit pas de manoeuvres
conjointes comme l'a précisé un porte
parole de l'otan chaque pays participent
à ces exercices sur invitation du
pakistan certes mais de manière autonome
cela n'en reste pas moins une prouesse
diplomatique pour islamabad
la dernière fois que les forces navales
russes et celle de l'alliance atlantique
avaient participé à deux même manoeuvre
c'était en 2011 il y a dix ans au large
de l'espagne